wir wollen uns jetzt näher beschäftigen
mit der position der linkspartei in
diesen dramatischen konflikt in diesem
krieg der jetzt auf europäischem boden
stattfindet und er ist uns sehr
zugeschaltet guten morgen herr gysi
guten morgen sie sind außenpolitischer
sprecher der linksfraktion und immer
wieder für eine überraschung gut alles
was ich immer gesagt habe ist an dem tag
gestorben an dem ein
völkerrechtswidriger krieg beginnt das
haben sie gestern in einem podcast
gesagt heißt das jetzt dass sie die
große russische invasion ohne wenn und
aber verurteilen
ohne wenn und aber es ist ein
verbrecherischer angriffskrieg nichts
anderes und das kann man und muss man
verurteilen und zwar schärfsten ihre
partei trotzdem das muss man sagen hatte
immer schon ein offenkundiges russland
problemen also soll heißen nicht
unwesentliche teile ihrer partei haben
immer verständnis für rabiate schritte
von putin geäußert warum kommt jetzt
erst die erkenntnis dass dieser mann
nach völkerrechts maßstäben ein
kriegsverbrecher ist
das hängt einfach damit zusammen dass
man immer gehofft hat dass er den
angriffskrieg doch nicht startet aber
diese hoffnungen sind zerstört wirklich
zerstört worden nicht alles was ich
kritisches gesagt habe was der besten
gemacht hat irgendwie nato mag ja
stimmen aber es ist zur makulatur
geworden weil jetzt eben punkte sich
entschieden hat einen
völkerrechtswidrigen verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg zu führen es gibt schon
tote zivilisten leiden und da gibt es
gar keinen anderen möglichen standpunkt
für eine linkspartei der immer eine
friedenspartei war ist und bleibt als
das schaffen zu fördern auch seine
legitimation für diesen angriffskrieg
also genozide und entnazifizierung ist
also offenkundig völliger blödsinn
also was als erstes in jedem krieg
stirbt das ist die wahrheit das ist
natürlich blödsinn und was wir da ein
gründer angibt ich darf nur daran
erinnern der irakkrieg von george bush
begann auch mit einer lüge dass die
massenvernichtungswaffen haben das ist
immer so im krieg dass man dann
rechtfertigungen sucht erfindet frei
erfindet darauf darf man sich überhaupt
nicht einlassen das ist wirklich unsinn
ich bin übrigens sie werden sich wundern
diesem fall auch für sanktionen aber für
sanktionen gegen die führung nicht gegen
die bevölkerung man muss das möglichst
ausschließen denn die bevölkerung kann
ja nichts dafür das ist schwer ich weiß
es aber das ist eine komplizierte
abwägung und ist nord stream zwei eine
sanktionen gegen die führung oder gegen
die bevölkerung für sie
bei nordstream zwei ärgert mich ja bloß
dass die grünen schon immer das kippen
wollten die usa wollten es auch immer
kippen damit wir ihr fracking gas kaufen
und was mich noch mehr ärgert ist dass
die usa erklärt haben die importe von
erdöl aus russland werden um keinen
liter reduziert uns will man's mal vom
gas abschneiden aber diese beziehen nach
wie vor die gleiche menge erdöl aus
russland das ist noch ein anderer punkt
im augenblick steht das nicht zur
debatte aber darüber müssen wir dann
später diskutieren weil ich nun auch
nicht einsehen dass die usa von uns
etwas verlangt was sie selber nicht
machen ganz im gegenteil aber ansonsten
müssen wir uns wirklich überlegen wie
wir putin treffen wie wir die führung
treffen aber möglichst die bevölkerung
verschonen abschalten oder nicht
abschalten jetzt zwölf sondern nord
stream 2
trotzdem zeigen liegt ja jetzt auf eis
da kann es jetzt auch liegen und wenn
hoffentlich der krieg irgendwann zu ende
ist wie auch immer dann müssen wir neu
darüber beraten auch mit den usa und
anderen also ich sage nochmal was nicht
geht ist dass wir auf erdgas verzichten
und sie importieren nach wie vor das
gesamte erdöl dass sie benötigen also
dass der zweitgrößte lieferant aus
russland da muss man übereinstimmung
herstellen es gibt dramatische
flehentliche hilfe appelle aus der
ukraine richtung westen man möge doch
wenn man jetzt wenigstens nicht mit
waffen unterstützen kann und will doch
bitteschön des swift sozusagen russland
abkoppeln von diesem internationalen
finanzsystem ist das für sie auch etwas
was in frage kämen weil sie gesagt haben
das müsste die führung treffen und damit
wäre ja die führung getroffen
ja das problem ist ein anderes natürlich
können wir russland ausschließen aus dem
swift aber es hat ja auch schon ein cdu
politiker darauf hingewiesen dass china
und russland dann ein gemeinsame neuer
währungsstrategen den dollar gegen den
euro ich bin nicht experte genug um das
beurteilen zu können aber das muss man
alles bedenken wissen sie ich habe eine
sorge die komischerweise kaum jemand
anders hat es gibt ja logischerweise
sanktionen gegen russland aber es gibt
ja auch viele sanktionen gegen china was
ich nicht möchte ist das für sie zu
einem bündnis zwingen stellen sie sich
doch mal vor china ist ökonomisch viel
stärker als russland russland ist
militärisch immer noch deutlich stärker
als china wenn die sich wirklich
zusammenschließen entsteht da ein
machtfaktor der für die demokratien für
den westen gar nicht beherrschbar ist
wir müssen lernen zwischen beiden
ländern zu differenzieren um das
möglichst zu verhindern und das hängt
dann auch mit dem swift und mit anderen
dingen zusammen das ist immer schwer
wenn ein krieg ist wenn es tote gibt
wenn es leid ist diskutiert man noch
nicht gerne über geld und solche sachen
nur wir müssen immer an die konsequenzen
und folgen denken nicht nur an morgen
sondern auch an übermorgen diese aber
putin glaube ich es erledigt der iss
erledigt und zwar wissen sie bald auch
da hat er ja doch immer eine mehrheit in
der russischen bevölkerung ich glaube
die hat er jetzt verloren und die
ukrainische bevölkerung wird widerstand
leisten den er gar nicht kennt sagt der
außenpolitische sprecher der linkspartei
vielen dank gregor gysi
bitteschön